the Gottlieb just joined us via zoom
Doug can you hear me I can in my car
listening as I do every morning taking
my dog for a walk and and yeah Odell
Beckham jr. jr. in the background and I
was I wanted to help you out here I I
completely disagree with you on cream
and I'll tell you why in a second but
the pettiness of Paul Pierce and I I'm
no Paul Pierce we graduated senior high
school he was my roommate at ABCD like
look Paul's a prideful guy and I think
the fact that he was a great player in
this and people don't talk about him I'm
sure that doesn't sit well with him but
look again he's doing nothing different
than what Isaiah has done for years hi
dad
and Jordan don't get along he's
downplayed Jordan for years and he's
doing the same but the biggest mistake
that he's making is what a lot of people
my age do talking about guys they never
saw a play you know like look no one
else was a great player will
Chamberlain's like my only not knowledge
of will Chamberlain's for my dad without
little chairman with dogs you know that
every big game he didn't show up in
every single one so I would just say we
should start from the bird and magic era
and then move forward I'm fine with that
but you know what Paul Paul's an analyst
and should be objective here and just
say look I had a rivalry with LeBron I
didn't get along with him and then if
you want to say here's my top five or my
top seven I'm fine with that he's an
analyst on ESPN also a possibility he
actually believed he believes this you
know he believes the problem is how he
supports his argument master if that's
your point
Fenster which is a really good look my
thing about cream and greens is a guy
who he checks all the boxes but here's
the thing
give me the moment give me just even one
moment when he and magic were on the
Lakers where it was Korean team it
wasn't I mean obviously the most famous
moment in magic rookie year was what he
did on the road against Philadelphia yep
and and when they beat the Boston
Celtics it was magic making the baby
skyhook like
and I know that Kareem was past his
prime but when Korean got to the Lakers
they didn't immediately Lin come til
they got Magic Johnson the wind magic
and bird took over the league I think
you start there then you go to Jordan
you gotta include Duncan maybe a you
know in Kobe in some of these modern-day
discussions and then I think you have
the LeBron James and Shaquille O'Neal
and some others as well but I just I
like look I get the the D you're a
Celtic you got to mention Bill Russell
but like did we never saw Bill Russell
play so it's really hard to get contact
creme was MVP and 85 in the finals yeah
listen I'm not saying he thought no I'm
not sitting here telling you that you're
an idiot for saying Kareem abdul-jabbar
is the greatest player of all time you
can make an argument Mike my
counter-argument to that
dan would be he just you know but I Doug
I was including college basketball in
this he's the greatest player he's had
if I look at high school college and the
NBA he's the greatest player of all time
greatest career MVPs won titles
allegedly and scoring blocks rebound he
did everything you wanted I I know you
if we said oh you're gonna start your
team with Kareem or Michael I know that
you're gonna say Michael there I might
to butt cream did everything and that's
why it was laughable the ESPN best
college basketball player it's not
closed it it is cream right yeah no I
listen yeah yeah I mean look go Russell
then they win 60 in a row with Casey
Jones at the University of San Francisco
Graham maybe not the overall dominance
of creamy
jelly I would send like if you're gonna
do your new college in fro then you put
Bill Russell in there as well he also
did to the coach player coach which is
which is unique I don't think Russell
was a great player though I think he was
the ultimate team player he was so
limited offensively Doug he was
unbelievers great at what he needed to
be great at and they had an unbeliever
Famers on that team at one point and you
had maybe the greatest coach of all time
okay but many of the times in which they
beat Wilt Chamberlain and he was if he
was and Wilt Chamberlain stats dipped
against the Boston Celtics unlike any
other time and will Chamberlain played
you know whether it's with the
Philadelphia Warriors when he played
with the Lakers he had Jerry West in
Elgin Baylor and his team and you know
only once and wilt was far past his
prime I like we can go round and round I
think is like I mean even like Bill
Russell Russell numbers were still crazy
there was but the game was totally
different there was very limited defense
there was no three-point shot it just
it's so and and look I'll take your work
work because you're the only one the two
of us so remember the history of
basketball because you're that old Dan
thank you but but but I just I think the
biggest mistake dudes make is like like
Paul like I love Paul we grew up in the
same area so he should have an affinity
for Matt Johnson probably has I don't
know how he feels about Kobe because
that was a contemporary it's it's really
hard to find guys who analyze basketball
who know the history of basketball when
it cuz when you're a kid you just you
don't have time if you're a player you
don't really have time to go and analyze
I'm the exception because I'm a coach's
son most of the great players they
weren't breaking down and we're doing
what Kobe was doing breaking down
Jordans moves they were just out there
hooping trying to get better playing
four or five games a day and so the best
perspective Paul can give you is hey I
played against all these guys let me
tell you Kobe was better than LeBron and
here's why that's where he can provide
insight that no one else can now it's
really hard to disconnect your own
personal feeling I will tell you that
there's a good group of former NBA
players some current NBA players are
like look LeBron played in a terrible
East when he played in Miami they know
it they they not only joined the super
team but remember they kicked out the
legs from the rafters and from the Cavs
and and so that took away any sort of
competition these yes when he was 22
when he did how they beat Detroit but
but we had a lot of weird genes come out
of the East member eilen Iverson came
out of the East was a one-man band we
weigh each was just that far down okay
let let me just let us
one this year do you think LeBron should
top-five player of all time yes okay
that's good
dog it's great to talk to you all right
thank you
it's a god League there